this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
and I'm with I'm Chris smart I'm a
vegetable pathologist at Cornell and
today we're at a kid field so um and
this is specifically cucumber so Chris
what do we have here why does these
plant look like they are like wilting or
dying yeah so this this plant um is
dying you're exactly right and let's try
to figure out what the issue is so we
can see that there's just a lot of
Browning of the
leaves um and and it it just doesn't it
doesn't look healthy you can see there's
a lot of Wilt as well and when you look
around the plant you'll also see some of
these bright yellow cucumber beetles now
sometimes those beetles uh have stripes
black stripes on them sometimes they
have spots so there's the spotted
cucumber Beetle and the striped cu
cumber Beetle but both of them transmit
a bacterial disease uh the name of the
disease is bacterial Wilt the name of
the bacterium is called erwinia
Tropa do all the uh beetles can have the
bacteria in them so if I see one Beetle
I will have the disease of mbits no and
in fact the the bacterium the bacterium
is inside the Beetle and uh when the
beetle feeds on the plant that's when
the bacteria moves into the plant and
gets into the veins and clogs the veins
of the plant but um The Beetles actually
over winter in the soil and if it's a
really cold winter more get killed off
and you won't see as much bacterial wil
the next year but if it's a warmer
winter then we you know you won't lose
as many cucumber beetles in in the
wintertime and then it'll be a much
worse year not every cucumber Beetle
will have it but
um as soon as one plant gets infected
then other cucumber beetles that visit
it can pick up the bacterium and spread
it to other plants so Chris you
mentioned that the the colder weather is
the the less cook barbos we will see CU
they will get killed off so are things
like plastic mulch or any other type of
mulch that provide like warmer
temperatures will um help the kumber be
to survive maybe yeah I mean most most
people will pull up the plastic mulch in
the winter anyway um so so you know
plastic mulch is actually great the the
problem with raised beds and plastic
mulches with cucurbits is that as you
can see right here the the fruit fall
off of the plastic of the raised bed and
they end up um you know in in the lower
area where they might be sitting in
water if it's a real wet summer like
we've had this year so cre as you also
said that the cucumber beetles uh feed
on the on the plant is there a specific
part of the plant that they have to feed
on or in order to transmit the disease
no so they don't they can uh they can
feed on any part of the plant a lot of
times you'll see them inside the flowers
and that's not going to be where uh
they're transmitting the most um they'll
they'll you know when when they get into
the the vein tissue um that's when
they're going to transmit the bacterium
into the vein and it can be a leaf it
can be a stem it can be the crown um it
can be any any part of the cucumber
plant and sometimes in a cucumber plant
actually you'll see like oh half the
plant is really wilting and the other
half isn't and that's probably because
the cucumber beetles fed on one part of
the plant and the bacterium hasn't
gotten to the crown or the other side of
the plant yet speaking of the crown do
you mind if I pull this up yeah all
right let's see what it looks like so
one of the things that you can tell the
difference
between uh bacterial Wilt and some of
the other root rotting diseases is that
you'll still have
um fairly decent Roots if you look here
you know when when I pulled it out
there's there's still a decent root
system uh in this incredibly wet soil
because it's been very wet this year
yeah um if it were uh pythium you might
see the roots be really really degraded
and the outer cortex might Slough off um
if it were a perhaps a fusarium you they
might be kind of pinkish uh but in this
case what you see is that the crown just
is looking incredibly unhealthy and if I
can break it open you know sometimes
it'll even look yellow or watery on the
inside and that's just a you know a sign
of bacterial W but a classic test for
bacterial Wilt is that people will cut
the plant at a crown or or at a stem and
put that stem into a glass of water and
within a minute you'll actually start to
see the bacteria streaming out of the
bottom and you think about this poor
Plant it's like its veins are just
completely clogged with the erwinia
bacterium so much so that if you put it
in a glass of water the bacteria will
just start streaming out is this how the
plant look like whenever it um isos
starting off or we will see like what
will be the earlier symptoms that we see
and that we can detect yeah so the
earliest symptoms are going to be
welting with bacterial Wilt it doesn't
get quite as yellow as you might see
with a disease um like uh cucurbit
yellow uh Vine decline it doesn't get
nearly as yellow and you see wilting
first the thing is is that on a hot
summer day you might see wilting in the
afternoon and then the next morning it
doesn't look wilted at all and so you
think oh it was just hot out the plants
got wilty and and and it's okay that
could be a first sign of bacterial Wilt
the other thing it could be is that uh
there's a disease uh phyo caused by phyo
capsy whole different type of pathogen
and that can also attack the crown and
cause that same symptom so it can be
really tricky to differentiate between
some of the many diseases that we have
on our uh cucumbers here in New York so
what will be your recommendation whether
to diagnose a disease and also a
management technique that you recommend
you can um you know do the do the put
the stem in the glass test to see if
there's bacterial streaming um and you
can also send don't send the whole plant
but you can send a portion of the plant
say from The Roots up to maybe a foot to
your Diagnostic lab and they can tell
you really relatively quickly if it's um
bacterial wilter knut in terms of
control strategies um controlling the
Cucumber beetle is really the best way
to go and and that can be hard to do in
a year when when there's a a lot of
beetle pressure uh another researcher at
Cornell is doing a super cool study that
looks at using low tunnels that are
Maybe This Tall uh to cover up the
plants when they're young and that way
it's it's like a row cover but it gives
the plants a little more height they're
called misot tunnels and that actually
prevents the cucumber beetles from
getting to the plants when they're young
and that's when they'll do the most
damage so we're really excited to see um
what Dr Sarah py finds out there are
there also some um varieties that are
like less attractive to The Beetles
maybe yes absolutely and um uh plant
breeders have been working really hard
to find you know plants that are
resistant to the beetle uh so far to my
knowledge there hasn't been any
resistance seen to the actual bacterium
that's in the veins of the plant um but
there is resistance to The Beetles and
it's absolutely true that cucumbers and
melons are more susceptible to this
disease than the other cucurbits and
that is because maybe the Cucumber
Beetle are more attracted to this plant
certainly yep okay so thank you so much
Chris um so if you want more information
you can look or um reach out to the
Cornell vegetable website thanks Chris
have a great day this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu